c'est un poste symbolique souvent
convoités et appréciée des habitants le
maire d'une commune est avant tout un
agent de l'état il est notamment
responsable de l'état civil c'est donc
lui qui peut vous marier c'est lui aussi
qui prend acte des naissances et des
décès sur le territoire communal en lien
avec ses missions historiques c'est
madame ou monsieur le maire qui est en
charge du recensement de la population
enfin le premier magistrat de la ville
doit organiser bien sûr l'ensemble des
élections durant les six années de son
mandat le maire en fait fait partie de
la vie locale
c'est un administré est là pour aider
ces ennemis seraient donc les communes
vont s'occuper du quotidien des idées
noires c'est à dire par exemple les
mariages les naissances une à s'occuper
des écoles va s'occuper des espaces
verts tout ce qui concerne finalement la
commune de proximité plus technique le
rôle exécutif le maire prépare et
applique les décisions du conseil
municipal
il prend des arrêtés municipaux
représentent la commune en justice et
les charges et aussi des pouvoirs de
police pour assurer la sécurité la
tranquillité publique
il peut s'appuyer sur la police
municipale évidemment pour réaliser
l'ensemble de ces tâches le maire peut
compter sur le travail d'agents et de
nombreux services
les mairies sont notamment responsables
de la gestion des écoles maternelles et
primaires
ils doivent donc organiser les activités
périscolaires le temps de restauration
ou encore le recrutement des atsem les
assistants territoriaux spécialisés des
écoles maternelles
autre compétence majeure d'une mairie
l'urbanisme et le logement et la mise au
point du fameux paix et lui le plan
local d'urbanisme ce document fixe les
règles à respecter pour les
constructions auteurs zones à préserver
ou encore objectifs sociaux enfin une
mairie doit s'occuper de la construction
et du fonctionnement des équipements
sportifs et culturels et votent les
subventions aux clubs et associations
depuis quelques années les domaines
d'action des communes var et une partie
est transférée à une collectivité qui
voit ses prérogatives augmenté
l'intercommunalité à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la communauté
d'agglomération est ainsi responsable
des espaces verts du réseau des
médiathèques des déchets de certaines
voiries ou encore de l'assainissement
des eaux pluviales et usées
non